[Music]
time once again for something people
really seem to enjoy called fan
Corrections let's do fan correct this of
course this is a segment where of
viewers try to find a real mistake that
we've made on our show they find a
mistake and then they alert us so far
there have been many challengers but no
winners
nobody's beaten us yet tonight a fan
named Nico Elliot thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
sketch we did last week about two Amish
guys hey Conan I was watching your show
on 412 and doing the part about Amish yo
mama jokes well thy mother is so ugly
she must wear two bonnets one on her
head and one on her face
the Amish guy on the Left had a wedding
ring which the Amish don't have so I got
you buddy and on your birthday I know I
got you buddy
no sorry Nico but I got you buddy yes
that guy was wearing a wedding ring but
he's not really Amish you see his name
is Vinny Manzoni he's on the run from
the mob and living with the Amish as
part of the federal witness protection
program
you think I'm making that up check out
this footage man I love my new life I
fit right in with these English how you
doing Vinnie Cody
Rocko how'd you find me fan correction
tell the devil Nico Elliot sent ya
happy now Neko you got someone killed
with your little fan correction you're a
murderer